hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you checking in to
see how your weeks going into July oh my
god it's the July 4th weekend Jesus
Christ I feel like every [ __ ] weekend
it's been July 4th how many more [ __ ]
burgers can I make him my [ __ ] grill
before they officially open the whole
[ __ ] thing well according to the
[ __ ] they're gonna shut everything
down again I mean this is a [ __ ]
there's a goddamn quagmire
I'll tell you right now man I've seen
some [ __ ] I've seen some people step
in some [ __ ] before they couldn't get
off their [ __ ] boot but this is some
the stickiest [ __ ] I've ever seen I mean
what the [ __ ] do you do here people got
to go to work they got to earn money but
then you got to stay home wideout [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] like like this this is
obviously not work though the the self
quarantine is not working or the self
quarantine the swell of self quarantine
nation it's not [ __ ] working
all right because all you need is one
mouth breathe and [ __ ] [ __ ] to go
out and get it and then it starts over
again so this ain't like back in the day
when they had influenza I'm going to
guess it was easier to [ __ ] get
people to quarantine back then simply
because there was less people you know
but then how the [ __ ] you
tell people what was up with no Facebook
out there on the Prairie I can tell you
that but I would also think the fact
that you could actually [ __ ] die of
it and people died on a regular [ __ ]
basis back then and death was a real
[ __ ] thing you know and then people
also knew how to hunt like well [ __ ] you
know worst case scenario I'll just go
back to [ __ ] shoot and [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] woods alright I ain't going down
everybody sounds like this in history
and on everybody who sounds dumb today
for some reason it's gonna have a
southern accent which is stupid I
literally did a bit about that the
prejudice against the southern accent
anyway speaking of that how [ __ ]
funny is it watching how affected a very
small portion of white women are with
that word Karen and they're there's such
[ __ ] idiots they're literally trying
to equate it to the n-word saying that
it's a racial slur i retweeted one of
them and it's just [ __ ] it is [ __ ]
amazing
it is really amazing and I don't know if
I've ever really seen maybe I'm just
flaking here as far as like a character
on TV that really tapped into in a real
way like somebody's inability to take
responsibility for their action you know
that back in the day when old Billy
broad-brush came on you know I [ __ ]
slapped the pay and all all these
[ __ ] broads none of them take
responsibility for that [ __ ] hanging
you you know it's men and women it's a
small like I want to say I'm gonna go
positive here and say it's a small
portion you doing I mean did white guys
ever get [ __ ] annoyed with cracker
it's just like you white yeah it's a
name you're gonna be fine you know well
maybe see more moderate now they're like
[ __ ] white guys saying that calling
them a chat or a brad is offensive and
like you know dude you know bro just for
like the record bro like I have one of
my best friends chad is like the [ __ ]
like best bro that I know dude
you know I actually you know the only
thing it actually bothers me it's not
the word it's the it's the that whole
bro thing that automatically that if you
wear a hat on backwards in you're good
at sports
that means you're a particular type of
person where on the other side if you're
in this if you're into like sci-fi and
you suck at sports that automatically
means that you're a good person that's
the what I kind of got a kick out of you
know so if I can catch a ball that means
I'm a [ __ ] but if it [ __ ] you know
bounces off my nose and I bleed on my
dungeon & dragon [ __ ] set then that
means I'm a good [ __ ] person anyway
it's all funny in the end of the day but
I guess we all have our sensitive parts
of our personality I'm in a great great
great [ __ ] mood did I even finish my
first idea so I just don't understand
why all the times they flooded the
economy with money to help out
corporations banks you know Airlines
Chrysler you know anything out there to
keep it [ __ ] going now it's the
[ __ ] working man out there and you
can't just flood the market with testing
free [ __ ] testing just go down there
get people tested if you come up with
the [ __ ] [ __ ] stay home if you don't
go to work and I know that they'll be
you know the people look at anybody's
keep the test coming
I mean why the [ __ ] wouldn't you do that
even if you can't get to everybody even
if there's gonna be some [ __ ] Lu
ain't [ __ ] testing me
I have a southern accent I represent
everything that bill doesn't like today
for some stupid reason sorry dude you
ain't [ __ ] testing me with that [ __ ]
what do you got a [ __ ] stick at my
ass no one said that actually just a
little swab and you know oh yeah first
first my nose that was the overly
homophobic person where it gets the
point of maybe you're a little curious
curiosity killed the cat
anyway I don't understand why they can't
[ __ ] do that and then you could get
people could go [ __ ] back to work
alright and you could just you could
just beat the [ __ ] out of this [ __ ]
thing I don't I don't get it I actually
do get it I do get it because they don't
give a [ __ ] I don't know they give a
[ __ ] it's also like you give good
governments not your [ __ ] parents you
know so I don't know I don't have any
solutions but gee bill why are you a
great mood I'll tell you why because I
was really [ __ ] up for like I don't
know probably about six weeks
this whole quarantine thing and not
working and all of this [ __ ] was really
starting to [ __ ] bother me and I was
really missing stand-up and doing this
[ __ ] that I love to do and traveling and
all of that but because of my childhood
I've learned that when something hurts I
just go I literally lie to myself that
it doesn't bother me
mm-hmm so then what ends up happening is
it just starts building up in me and
then just comes out and like misdirected
anger so I was getting really short with
my family which is brutal and I couldn't
figure out what the [ __ ] problem was
and I took my wife for a drive and we
were up on Mulholland Drive
and I looked uh sorry making you all
yawn I looked out over the valley and I
was like god dammit I miss flying I
[ __ ] miss it and I just said you know
what [ __ ] this and I just called the
bunny mine up was this beautiful
helicopter I said can I just can't rent
this [ __ ] thing just fine he said
yeah so I went up and I flew a an a-star
three-fitty
the one that the cops and the news
reporters have and I I can't even tell
you what what it did for me
psychologically just to get out there
and I just [ __ ] missed it and I was
really nervous because I usually fly
robinson's I wasn't nervous I was just
sort of just like ah I'm gonna suck at
this
I haven't flown I hadn't flown since
January 21st the longest layoff I think
I me was almost [ __ ] six months and I
gotta tell you the little bit of
instrument training that I've done I was
able to fly you know really well for me
for that amount of time off I mean I
still wasn't you know the greatest or
whatever but god damn it did I have a
good time and I only flew for like an
hour you know I just said listen I got
it I got the little window here you can
fly for an hour and then I got to get
home and make sure I'm home in time you
know to put my kid over to bed and lo
and behold I got out there really
quickly you know we went right up did a
quick loop around it was funny I kept
cakes extending how far the loop was
because I was going on like Robinson
time in my head where I would be flying
like roughly like you know 100 knots and
this thing was just wanted to fly but I
be if I took a 44 I don't know I'm just
used to the Robinson's put it that way
and this [ __ ] thing was just it felt
like at one point was just like lurching
forward on me going up towards 120 knots
you didn't want to fly above that and I
was like I need to slow down
here it was also too with the the a star
you feel like you're flying like a nose
down attitude and I just kept looking at
the little ball there and I was kept
being above the horizon and I was still
climbing I was it the [ __ ] am i doing
and I just eased to stick forward eased
it forward because I'm used to flying
Robinson's and I'm worried about a low G
[ __ ] but they blow G push over
whatever [ __ ] they call it and I was
like oh wait this is a fully articulated
main rotor system I can slam this thing
forward but I still didn't do it I was
still leading with the collective and
because the main rotor turns the
opposite way I always just the guy
teaching me my instrument or was anyways
I I learned that your left foot moves
with the collective which is the
basically the emergency brake looking
thing for you people who don't fly and I
was able to slow down and that type of
[ __ ] and man was a great flight flew
right along the 101 took off out of Van
Nuys which I never do made a left on the
101 right over the 405 right past the
Macy's all those beautiful houses in the
hills there in in the valley and then we
wanted money to the Cahuenga Pass and
there's those you know those wires there
that can get you [ __ ] killed so I
always make sure I'm high enough right
universal then there's the wires and
then on the right you go right by the
Hollywood Bowl then you're into
Hollywood and then there's the Capitol
Records building and then straight ahead
you got Silver Lake and then Dodger
Stadium and then I went around downtown
LA then followed the ten took a look
down to see how they were coming along
with the new Rams San Diego Chargers Los
Angeles Chargers Stadium
I'm anthing looks like a [ __ ]
spaceship landed obviously I was looking
at that north of the tent because all
south of the ten that's all bravo
airspace lax which usually has like
[ __ ] both runways open and you look
over and you'll see like you know two
[ __ ] planes
giant [ __ ] commercial jets and then
you know if you look further ahead
there's two landing and these little
ones behind it you know it's [ __ ]
bananas so then we went up over Beverly
Hills Pacific Palisades up Malibu went
around was at point doing out there
and then I just bagged the right went up
over the hills came out Calabasas
Kardashian country and then just
rejoined the 101 and right back to Van
Nuys and it was [ __ ] sick I
absolutely loved it and I just realized
you know I just talked to my wife about
it and I was just going like you know
what I think I want to start that
instrument training again you know and
then I just picked the hours of when my
daughter's napping
you know and I just said I'll crush it
in the morning with my son
you know I'll handle everything and then
you know when I put my daughter down for
the nap then I'll go run out I'll do
like an hour-long lesson or something
like that and come back a couple to
three times a week it gives me something
to work towards because I'll be honest
with you guys I started [ __ ] cleaning
out my office and I'm essentially done
and when I'm done with that I don't have
anything else to [ __ ] do which means
I will then what I found is then I'll
then settle into this [ __ ] depressive
thing of not being able to do what I
love doing for a living which is going
out and making you [ __ ] laughs
that's what I do and then I hear you
laugh and it makes me feel good about
myself and I haven't had that for four
[ __ ] months and I'm feeling sad beard
yeah I don't think I realized how much I
got out of doing stand-up like I knew it
in the beginning it was the most
exciting [ __ ] thing ever that I was
do I couldn't [ __ ] believe that I was
doing it it was what I always wanted to
do was what I fantasized about doing but
I just never thought I would do it
because I fantasized about a bunch of
[ __ ] when I was a kid and nothing ever
happened and I was really living in my
head
and just I don't to this day I don't
know how to [ __ ] when I think about the
things that fell into place that just
sort of threw me onto that path I easily
could have been thrown off of it and I
don't know where the [ __ ] I would be
right now but in the beginning when I
would get a laugh it would so [ __ ]
fill me up because it was all new and
exciting and all of that type of [ __ ]
and then after a while become something
that you've done for a long time and
then yours my happiness was bent on if
the new thing I tried worked or if I
something I just showed some sort of
growth although I will say I was having
more fun than I'd ever [ __ ] had right
before this whole [ __ ] thing
happened but anyways I miss I cannot
[ __ ] wait I cannot wait for this [ __ ]
to be over and as they say that they
might be shutting us down again but it
seems like everybody's finally on board
using the masks and once again people
that is not a political issue if we
could just keep that out of the red tie
blue tie [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is this could have been such a
great opportunity after all these years
of the divide between the right and left
it could have been such a great
opportunity to [ __ ] bring people
together you know on some way we're all
working on this common thing but
everything's everything just becomes
devices that's all they do and I just
can't believe people keep taking the
[ __ ] bait if they can turn 9/11 into
a politically divisive [ __ ] moment
you know what I remember really early on
people tried to blame Bush that that
happened and then people on the right
were like well everything leading up to
it was going on when Clinton was in
office it just became [ __ ] sick what
are you guys doing
[ __ ] idiots don't you know for all
this [ __ ] about people who watch sports
being morons which I definitely am if
you learn a lot playing sports for all
these [ __ ] people it's [ __ ] rape
culture whatever they though these
[ __ ] [ __ ] are never you know
played sports you [ __ ] learn
immediately then if you're not [ __ ]
with the team not like how much power
you have to [ __ ] the whole thing up and
you learn that all it takes is a couple
two three people to turn the [ __ ]
locker room in the wrong [ __ ]
direction against the coach and that's
all it takes you got 40 [ __ ] people
on the team you get two three people who
don't [ __ ] buy in the whole thing
goes down the [ __ ] and you're not
gonna have any wins and as far as I can
say goddamn it CNN and Fox News are
those [ __ ] two or three [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] locker room anyway sorry so I
think I'm gonna start back up flying
again and get my instrument I mean it
really bothered me like I don't like not
finishing [ __ ] to have it I got into at
least a love not finishing [ __ ] I was
the biggest procrastinator ever but it's
the habit that I sort of got into well
definitely got into once I got into show
business where I just sort of learned
really quickly that nobody gives a [ __ ]
whether your dream comes true or not
that's nobody else's responsibility so
and I learned that you know if I don't
you know if I have an idea great
whatever right if I don't [ __ ] finish
that idea and then bring it to my
[ __ ] people who then spit it out into
this business nothing's gonna [ __ ]
happen and sitting around saying you got
nothing to happen if you go out and make
something now you got something
happening so I kind of got into that
which has helped me out I was gonna say
hasn't helped me my [ __ ] diet which
I'm back on again turning the
I can ship around my problem with
dieting is I just look at it like a
number I want to get my stomach flat and
get to this [ __ ] weight and then I
look at it like that's done and then I
go back to [ __ ] eating steak and
cheeses and not having a root beer
floats and all the dumb [ __ ] I do now
cuz I'm [ __ ] sober back in the day
I'd go back to boozing so whatever I
have to look at it as a lifestyle change
I think that's what I need to do
alright let's plow ahead here let's talk
about some NHL by the way the Troubadour
thing was a huge success we had a
hundred posters and they sold out in
like the first hour and I and I knew the
Troubadour was a legendary venue but
let's uh let's read a quick little
Wikipedia thing here and I'm gonna
definitely do another show next month
trooper Dahl was open in 1957 initially
was a little coffee shop and it quickly
moved to its initial location it's its
permanent location now so I would guess
that that was somewhere around like 1960
or something like that the first couple
two three years it was somewhere over on
La Cienega before it moved to Santa
Monica Boulevard just east of Doheny so
here's some of the people that the
Troubadour played an important role
height accident Jackson Browne BTS the
birds they had their first performance
ever
the birds Eagles Elton John's first
American performance was there Carole
King loved Joni Mitchell
van Morrison Bonnie Raitt Red Hot Chili
Peppers Linda Ronstadt JD's souther
James Taylor Tom Waits another prominent
and successful performers who played
performances there establishing the feud
the future their future fame 1962
comedian Lenny Bruce was arrested on
obscenity charges for using the word
schmuck on stage one of the arresting
officers was Sherman block who would
later become the Los Angeles County
Sheriff
buff
Springfield debuted at the club in 1966
Randy Newman started out there on August
25th 1970 Neil Diamond who just recorded
his first live album at the album at the
troubadour introduced Elton John who
performed his first show in the United
States at the troubadour Comics Cheech
and Chong and Steve Martin were
discovered there in the early 70s 1974
John Lennon and his friend Harry Nielsen
were ejected from the club for drunkenly
heckling The Smothers Brothers 1975
Elton John returned into a series of
special anniversary concerts and in
November 2007 James Taylor and Carole
King played a series of concerts
commemorating the nightclubs 50th
anniversary in reuniting the two from
the 1970s performance and then it just
continued on new wave and punk came
along Bad Religion flipper the meat
puppets napalm death and red cross la
residents and proto grunge bands The
Melvins hour Melvin's had played the
troubadour stage twenty four times and
Counting as of 2019 you get it right and
then into my era glam bands metal bands
hair bands [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] you
want to call them candy Cinderella Guns
and Roses la guns Motley Crue poison rat
warrant and wasp became synonymous with
the club Guns & Roses played their first
show at the Troubadour and we're also
discovered by David Geffen Geffen Fiona
Apple look at it mud honey it just keeps
going Papa Roach Radiohead and so on and
so forth so that's why we did the show
over there I mean Jesus Christ we could
spend a lifetime just listening to that
goddamn music oh speaking of which
speaking of Billy [ __ ] white cakes
here old tres Lecce [ __ ] thighs the
whitest [ __ ] in person ever dough slay
chase that's what they call my [ __ ]
legs
I actually downloaded some hip-hop which
I never [ __ ] do because I never know
what anything is this is what I
downloaded Marco Polo and masterrace I
downloaded a song nostalgia and then
sitting on Chrome that album I
downloaded EPMD because I'm an Eric
sermon fan
I got strictly business and out of
business it's funny that guy gave me all
that rap [ __ ] and I [ __ ] didn't
download any of it I still have it so I
got to get to that and then I downloaded
a leaders of the new school Busta Rhymes
first group a future without a past and
then I don't know how this got into my
timeline cuz I wasn't following him you
know not on a personal level I just you
know there's a lot of [ __ ] people to
follow on Instagram Fat Joe was talking
about this guy Hector Lavoe who's like
you know I guess the king of salsa music
and [ __ ] like that I've always found
that stuff fascinating particularly I
mean the drums already confusing enough
I'm white as [ __ ] so I don't know
anything about that but the piano
playing and salsa music I find
fascinating how it fits into the whole
thing and I just downloaded Hector Lavoe
his greatest hits and I got to tell you
man it's just there's not a bad one on
it and I have no idea what he's singing
about or anything I absolutely [ __ ]
love it so there you go little
helicopter flying a little bit of
[ __ ] new music and all of a sudden
I'm right as rain get ready for the 4th
of July here I'm back to working out and
eating right I'm gonna do turkey burgers
on 4th of July just cuz we're trying to
eat up some [ __ ] that's in the fridge
I would [ __ ] go out to get the
burgers I max might still get B gotta
have a burger right I got hot dogs too
and I'm all out of cigars so I'm back to
my cigar sabbatical I had a great
[ __ ] time I follow la aurora cigars
on instagram and they had this great
picture
of those torpedo cigars they had they
had the one that's in the gold the gold
one I don't know I'm the set I like the
Sapphire in the afternoon and an emerald
if it's nighttime and I had a little
cappuccino that I don't even drink
coffee but there's just something about
that whole thing and it's always on some
like you know it's like sunny but
there's an overhang there's some sort of
coffee shop thing going on you know it's
just what the whole it's what [ __ ]
it's literally literally what life is
about if you can occasionally do that in
the afternoon nice Laura sapphire a
little cappuccino even though I don't
[ __ ] drink hanging with the buddy or
maybe just being by yourself and just
not thinking of anything I mean
that'sthat's what that's what the [ __ ]
it's all about alright let's let's do a
little I think I got an ad read don't I
I believe I did
I can get this [ __ ] window out of the
way here all right okay all things
comedy football tournament okay oh by
the way I got a little bone to pick with
24-hour Sports network's guys I've
watched a ton of sports in my life but I
didn't watch every game ever and I don't
remember every game ever could you when
you've showin old games which is all
sports fans have do you have to have the
[ __ ] result it's always like
Cardinals clinched the pennant Yankees
beat the [ __ ] Brooklyn Dodgers let's
say I was watching a [ __ ] game from
1950 to now I know the 55 Brooklyn
Dodgers finally wanted so I knew in 52
they weren't gonna win it but like they
had I mean who was anybody else it was
like the San Francisco Giants I'm like I
know they won won like 54 something like
that somewhere in there maybe it was 52
I could actually enjoy the [ __ ] game
the game anyway all right well if you
want some new football we got so we got
the best we can give you right now all
things comedy football tournament all
things comedy is teaming up with the
sports gambling podcast to give you
football in July the SGP
guys are going to be simulating the two
nineteen NFL playoffs on Madden and
doing live play-by-play the games will
be streamed on the all things comedy
youtube channel and you can even bet on
the games they're going to be using the
20/20 roster so Camden is going to be on
the Patriot Plus they're giving away
$10,000 in sports book credits for their
playoff contest the first game starts on
July 3rd 8:00 p.m. Eastern for all the
information go to sports gambling
podcast.com slash ATC all lowercase that
sports gambling podcast.com slash ATC by
the way speaking of which what do you
guys think about Cam Newton to the New
England Patriots personally I love it I
know by the end he's kind of getting a
bad rap down there in Carolina but I
just think that that's not a good
organization or that I shouldn't say
that they're not in a good place right
now that organization and with his
talents he got frustrated and you know I
think he goes into the with the Patriots
and you know the starting position is up
for grabs even though they said it was
the other guy I don't know his [ __ ]
name sorry two kids under three and
under what do you want for me I love
that signing I love that siding and I
think we shall see how that works out
but now that gives us definitely more
than a fighting chance you know my nuts
can't
got plenty left in the tank if things
doesn't want don't work out with the
other guy right
am I crazy I don't know I'm just wishful
[ __ ] thank you so next next season
the season coming up here which we
should all be excited about both the
Colvin who knows what the [ __ ] gonna
happen my thing was if the Patriots
didn't somehow get back there I wanted
to see the Kansas City Chiefs first the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers and I wanted to see
Tom Brady win number seven
and that would just that would be it and
then I would I just want to hear what
the [ __ ] they would say then you know
how he [ __ ] cheated then I thought
that that's what the five just then what
the [ __ ] he gonna say
all right Buffalo Sabres trade with the
Bruins rumor right type in this [ __ ] in
here
the trade rumor and so that that Ifill
guy whatever the [ __ ] the eiffel tower
guy Jack Eichel to the Bruins seems
unlikely yeah [ __ ] well they were gonna
it was like Jake to Brust two other guys
and then to number one picks
I just think two number ones was too
much but that would have been that would
have been crazy although I love de
brusque but I'm wondering if the other
Bruins going going to or or do they have
any plans to address the fact that we
have nobody to go out there and really
just like settle it down you know that
people can just take liberties with us
because I really think that the st.
Louis Blues exposed the Bruins Nashville
and a San Jose I believe Nashville I
think that was you know they just went
out there and punched him in the face
and we had nothing we had no [ __ ]
answer and that was just such a [ __ ]
weird year this was killing me manis I
know that they're gonna do the playoffs
I just need to put that year
behind me it was a particularly
difficult [ __ ] loss where was just
like what the [ __ ] I thought these I
thought you weren't allowed to do that
anymore well you weren't allowed to do
it but they can save never one one in 50
years I was just like what the [ __ ] and
and then I got this weird thing where it
was just like I loved a style of play
st. Louis was playing I missed hockey
being like that but then they took it
away from us
and then one team's playing it and then
they stopped calling it they called it
all [ __ ] decade they penalized that
out of the [ __ ] game I I know I know
I sound like [ __ ] I'm on a goddamned
loop here I'll never get over it I'll
get over it
I just need and I just need another
Stanley Cup to go by alright so those
were the trade rumors and I was just
excited just to hear a [ __ ] trade
rumor that something was gonna happen so
all right before I get out of here I
just want to thank all you guys that
tuned in to the Troubadour podcast and
donated money during this this [ __ ]
nightmare that we're going through I
know a lot of people aren't working so
thank you so much for that and I'm kind
of glad I didn't look at the troubadours
Wikipedia page or I would be even more
intimidated going on that stage which by
the way is the stage is so [ __ ] small
it's ridiculous because in in my head
and every time I've gone to see a show
there you know the place is packed it
just feels like it's bigger and I've
always felt I was talking about that on
the podcast like I remember the first
time I went to the Comedy Cellar
during the day I couldn't believe how
[ __ ] small it was at night when the
lights are out and it's [ __ ] packed
and the you know there's all those great
comics there and you're feeling like man
oh my god you hear what so-and-so said
and this person did that and just sort
of drives you to get better
it just feels [ __ ] gigantic and I
remember getting up there just being
like this little ass room scares the
[ __ ] out of me at night I can't believe
this anyway at least it did back in the
day it scared me and then now
now it just feels like [ __ ] home oh
and I miss New York I haven't been there
in forever alright well that's it but
guess what Oh Billy fly boy is back back
on the stick there and I'm gonna get
back into this [ __ ] give me something to
work towards and if I've learned
anything in this [ __ ] business as
much as I talk about wanting to retire
when I'm 70 which I might want to just
going through this [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
what it feels like to be [ __ ] retired
just puttering around the [ __ ] house
I would go out of my [ __ ] mind out of
my [ __ ] mind so I don't see that
happening at any point which is good
because I don't think that bankers at
this point will let you retire keep
running on that we'll keep we'll keep
putting your money in play so we can
sort of take it if you keep it on the
sidelines we'll take even more of it you
know you do what you want with it all
right let's not get into that oh by the
way I did a great bill Bert episode this
guy Anthony I already forget his last
name talking about Bitcoin and that type
of stuff it was really really
fascinating and a lot of people were
saying like Bill you look bored as [ __ ]
I wasn't bored as [ __ ] I had my head in
my hands because I was thinking about
how if the dollar were to go away and I
had to start all over again
on the other side of 50 with two kids
you know three and under it was pretty
scary so and I actually thought that I
was going to get accolades for actually
asking some really good questions but of
course I didn't you know why cuz the
Internet is like that friend you have
that for 20 takes you 20 years to be
like why am i hanging out with this
person it takes you 20 years to get rid
of him because you met him early on in
life that's what it is they're almost
sentimental and you didn't notice that
they were as their life wasn't working
out that they were slowly dragging down
yours
I say that as the Internet and the power
of the Internet brought me everything
that I have I think so I'm sorry
Internet maybe I'm the thing that the
Internet needs to get rid of all right
that is the podcast everybody hang in
there where you goddamn mask if you can
get tested get [ __ ] tested and for
the love of God let's all try to be
pulling from the same side here can we
all pull in the same direction there
Jesus Christ but let's just lip service
you know it ain't gonna happen now [ __ ]
you some positive it's gonna happen it's
gonna happen people are gonna stop
watching 24 hours news networks they're
gonna reach out to that neighbor they're
gonna realize that it's okay to be a
little bit different all right reach out
from a safe distance with their neighbor
right so what's gonna happen I don't
know maybe bitcoins the answer I don't
know all right that's the podcast
everybody go [ __ ] yourselves have a
great weekend you [ __ ] happy 4th of
July to everybody and I will I will talk
to you on Monday hey what's going on
it's bill burr and it's the Monday
morning podcast for Monday July 2nd 2012
what's going on it's the first week of
July oh my god the summer is just flying
by I can't can you believe it can you
believe that it's just you like can you
believe that we spent all of June going
can you believe it's June
hey people who say that even though I
make fun of it all the time which
probably annoys the [ __ ] out of you but
I hate people who [ __ ] live in the
past you know like what did you think
that you were going to achieve in June
yeah oh did you get a sunburn good well
then it was a good month yes time is
flying by yes you are gonna [ __ ] die
so why don't you quit sitting around
talking about how it's going by and why
don't you go do something huh
hypothetical person that I never even
heard say this [ __ ] do you know this
allegedly an asteroid not allegedly it I
guess there is an asteroid I mean five
[ __ ] no there isn't one it's not like
I have a telescope it's goddamn
scientists I think they do that just so
they can keep they can have a job they
just look through this giant telescope
nobody else looks through it what you
see kill everybody unless you give us
four billion dollars but you're [ __ ]
nerds that's I think the scientists at
that level they're just like bankers at
that level just complete corrupt pieces
of [ __ ] you know every once in a while
you see a good one you know you meet an
honest one that'll sit there and be like
you know ah I don't know what to tell
you we've pretty much mapped out all the
way to the end of the universe and I
still have just as many questions as
when I started which once again is why
that poor Mathias or whatever the [ __ ]
it was called was such a good movie I
can't remember the names so anyways it's
supposed to be evidently there's this
asteroid heading right towards us you
know and rather than just letting it
happen you know and just ending the
[ __ ] movie we're gonna send some [ __ ]
up there to try to land on it and make
[ __ ] with its trajectory we're gonna we
can shoot some stuff at it and then and
then what and then what we're gonna keep
living until we destroy the entire
[ __ ] atmosphere and just make this
whole place unlivable alright we're done
it's over you don't I mean you ever go
to a [ __ ] like Vegas or you go in
Atlantic City and you look up on a
billboard you're like that [ __ ]
is still doing shows what is he doing
it's over nobody [ __ ] cares go
[ __ ] figure out I make your own jam
you know your own jelly and started
start a new business no one wants to
[ __ ] listen to you sing that goddamn
song that was a hit in 1974 the day
Libya
they died you imagine that poor bastard
singing that so he's even still alive if
he's dead is because of that song and
I'm gonna sing that for 40 [ __ ] years
and they would say again buddy Oh
Madonna did a cover of that didn't she
did she do a house version and some gay
guys with some tied off shirts behind
her making it new yet keeping it old um
she's uh you know what's amazing about
her cuz she continued to work out you
know it's [ __ ] incredible her body is
like you know looks like a [ __ ] 18
year old but there's some reason that
you can't you can't work out on your
face there's no like face pull-ups and I
don't give a [ __ ] if you get that
facelift [ __ ] and everything you know
you still look old you just can't you
can't [ __ ] beat it which is why you
don't sit around going oh my god it's
[ __ ] July already with you Bud Light
and your cigarette shut your face you're
freckled [ __ ] I live in the past a lot
I do every morning when I take my dog
for a walk I listen to [ __ ] music and
half the time I'm fan I'm always
fantasizing that's me singing it and
playing like you guys do that [ __ ] like
you're like the you know like a utility
infielder that can like play any
position like I can play every
instrument when I'm listening to the
song and whoever is the standout in that
moment of the song but it better be the
singer the or the [ __ ] tambourine
player whatever's stealing my focus
that's who I am and half the time I'm
doing it thirty years ago in my high
school auditorium and the whole school
is going wow that guy is awesome and
every once in a while I'll actually step
out of the fantasy and go bill you know
there's really something [ __ ] wrong
with you
and then I just laugh you know um I
throw my head back and I cackle and then
my dog looks at me like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you and then she takes a [ __ ]
and I pick it up that's my morning
that's how my morning works then I come
back and I make my
little breakfast underrated [ __ ] such
a Boston [ __ ] cooking cooking for
yourself and even more underrated
cooking for your friends I actually I
worked with Kevin Shea [ __ ] hilarious
Jason lawhead Cleveland's own and that's
not a lie that's the truth
Cleveland's own Jason lawhead who's just
growing by leaps and bounds keeps
getting funnier and I actually I made
those guys at dinner before we went out
before we went out to Ontario the Inland
Empire I was teasing them all [ __ ]
weekend about that name the [ __ ]
Inland Empire who do you guys plan on
conquering next just saying [ __ ] like
that it really is a impressive badass
name cuz I think they actually call it
the ie which is really bad you should
just call it the Inland Empire you know
when you just have a regular name like
Pittsburgh you got to come up with
something to try to like jazz it up like
you know when you come into the burg
when you come in to be more you know and
it's yeah I almost said the most
corniest joke ever can you be more
douchey oh really [ __ ] you it's Monday
morning I'm entitled to that well you
live in a place it's the Inland Empire
you don't you don't have to [ __ ] you
don't have to make up a name you know
what that [ __ ] reminds me of I
remember a long time ago
at the height at the tail end of the
height of that [ __ ] Def Jam style of
stand-up comedy where you could just
talk about white people like they were
borderline [ __ ] and white people
would just sit there and laugh even
though none of it made sense and you
could even relate to it but the
political correctness needle was at its
peak so you you just felt like you had
to laugh because if you didn't then you
were maybe some roundabout racist do you
remember that oh is this just my world
um I saw this one-man show on Broadway
and this guy was doing this whole bit
and he goes yeah me and my oh my friends
this latin dude he goes me and my
friends would go we'd go into Maddy
Haddie and then he goes that's Manhattan
for all you white people and everybody
laughed it's like that just right there
I just zoned out of it that whole
[ __ ] show it's like [ __ ] you you
can't you think I can't figure that out
like that's some sort of like you're
like you're some Apache and I'm the
goddamn I'm Japanese and I can't break
the [ __ ] code I'm in Manhattan you
dumb [ __ ] sorry I'm watching this in
Kentucky
I'm in [ __ ] Manhattan Jesus Christ
[ __ ] remix the name of this goddamn
town Hindman and it is a town Manhattan
is a town I know it's a bunch of people
there and everything but it's really
[ __ ] small with no traffic you can
drive from one end to the other in like
ten minutes
I mean you're hauling ass but you can do
it on the highways on the side I mean do
that with any [ __ ] town out there
right
and they just got everybody jammed
together and [ __ ] you know shooting
up into the sky that's the thing about
New York I told you that before is is
like you got a uh you should live there
at some point in your life and do it
sooner rather than later do it like your
20s and then a little bit in D of 30s
and then get the [ __ ] out that's perfect
that's [ __ ] perfect I was just
talking to me about that this morning we
were cracking up about it like how we
got I mean I actually stayed there too
long
but got out at the right time you know
what I mean you know it is about man you
just can't get any [ __ ] privacy
everybody's just jammed in with each
other and then like you don't give a
[ __ ] when you're young when you can go
out and drink until [ __ ] 3:00 in the
morning wake up still have ABS and go to
work at 7:00 in the morning you know to
[ __ ] with some third-world countries
economy or whatever the hell it is those
[ __ ] do down on Wall Street right you
can do that but [ __ ] you start
getting into your 30s and you just you
can't do it anymore you just want to
come home and you want [ __ ] space you
want quiet
um you know you can't [ __ ] sit there
and then there's gonna be some new
20-something year old moving in next
year he's gonna be [ __ ] raging for
three years and going through breakups
and [ __ ] screaming it [ __ ]
girlfriends and all that crap and then
there's gonna be the person down the
hall that's like 10 years older than you
all right and you're starting to see
them slipping into that you know getting
a few too many pets
I'm becoming like a agoraphobic you know
what I mean it just gets depressing
after well so now it's it's now it's
great I can live out here and then I'll
come back there I'll do a gig I hang for
like a week and then I get the [ __ ] out
of there but I gotta admit when I go
into the comedy clubs it's [ __ ] it's
horrific I walk in and I'm looking for
familiar faces my eyebrows are up and
I'm looking around and there's nobody
there that I remember anymore and it
yeah it [ __ ] kills me it's it's why I
hate going home to my hometown I hate it
because I moved away so long ago when I
go back it's like a [ __ ] time warp
and I think I'm gonna walk around town
seeing people that I know and I don't
see anybody and then maybe you run into
somebody that you do know and hopefully
they've been going to the gym because if
they haven't they're gonna quickly
remind you how [ __ ] old you are and I
swear to God at that point I want to
kill myself
then what the [ __ ] do I do how do I get
out of that depression that's been my
whole I don't what the [ __ ] is in my
throat here hang on a second hang on one
second I got a [ __ ] hang on
all right I'm back head hit pause there
one of the rare times they have to hit
the pause button I which went outside I
just you know hocked it up and just spit
all over these plants and second I did
it I started laughing because I know
that plants are just like [ __ ] really
you know plants poor bastard you know
what sucks about being a plant is you
can't [ __ ] you can't like move can't
like you know oh here comes some [ __ ]
spittle and just sort of like slip a
punch yeah I think that's what sucks
about being a plant plant is you can't
you can't slip a punch it would be my
number one reason you know and then
you're sitting there and a bunch of fire
ants or whatever the [ __ ] they are some
sort of insect locusts just start eating
you when you're just sitting there you
know it's like you got [ __ ] cement
shoes on you know I bet after this
[ __ ] asteroid mert if it mercifully
hits this [ __ ] planet alright and
ends us and we go down just like the
dinosaurs like I think plants are gonna
take over next
and there's gonna be a big moment in
their life when one of them finally has
the sense to pull like part of their
roots out of the ground and just move
over a couple inches then they'll
gradually they'll grow feet right and
then once they do that then you'll
probably have your first like
hand-to-hand combat somebody's gonna get
raped you know and then they'll invent
some stuff and then they'll think that
they're special and then they'll invent
this invisible guy in the sky and then
they'll fight over who has the right
visible guy and then another asteroid is
gonna hit that's what I think keep
happening I think God just keeps making
[ __ ] and waiting for people to [ __ ]
figure it out and he just keeps going at
God these ones that dumb to write you
everything like what he's doing on this
planet is it's like somebody trying to
build a hot rod you know and we're like
the transmission and we just keep
slipping and they just have [ __ ] us
you know what this doesn't fit this
engine and they just [ __ ] throws an
asteroid at the goddamn thing no well I
do anyway so I was mentioning earlier
that I leo get in here sit out this
[ __ ] dog goes out there I don't
understand it she goes out I left the
door open she goes out in the backyard
and she lays in the Sun until she's
panting like she just ran a marathon
then she gets up drinks a bunch of water
and then lays in the shade and then does
it all over again and then at some point
she [ __ ] goes over and just starts
eating the grass little blades of grass
and I get stuck in the back of her
throat and then she goes for the rest of
the [ __ ] day why do you do that huh
what are you gonna involve where you can
[ __ ] speak to me all right get over
there and lay down please do it do as I
say hey what are you going Cleo get over
here [ __ ] walk away from me on my
podcast lay down down
sit stop looking at me like that
alright go outside go on get out of here
see that that's gonna be a horrible
parent all right here's a [ __ ] ice
cream anyways yes so cooking for
somebody it's [ __ ] great
you know what I love about it there's a
rush that comes as they're coming over
you know you're trying to time it so
it's [ __ ] perfect you're trying to
make it look good and then there's this
panic that you're gonna [ __ ] it up and
that there's gonna be this awkward
silence because it sucks right and this
is thing I'm cooking for two comedians
so if it sucks they're gonna tell me
especially that [ __ ] Kevin Shea he
doesn't give a [ __ ] that guy you know
kept by the way is an unbelievable
singer but he's embarrassed I don't know
he has like this hidden talent like he
[ __ ] I caught him one time when I
walked in the green room he was singing
about himself I thought he had the
[ __ ] radio on he's unbelievable so
ladies get him to sing for you when you
go and see him out on the road Kevin
shake sh e a so anyways I [ __ ] yeah
there's like this rush like I think I
know they're gonna like it I think I
think it sucks and fortunately I pulled
it off and they loved it and I didn't
get trashed by them the entire [ __ ]
way out there that would have been a
long drive [ __ ] told you you could cook
um you're listening to the Monday
morning podcast everybody I hope you're
having a good Monday settling into the
July 4th weekend or middle of the week
then don't you hate when like the July
4th what's it what's it all Wednesday
2nd 3rd 4th yeah Wednesday ah that [ __ ]
yeah yeah I mean cuz if it's a Tuesday
if it lands on a Tuesday or a Thursday
maybe they'll give you that Monday at
that Friday off you could somehow get a
four-day [ __ ] weekend out of it or
even still even if they don't give you
the Friday you just go Monday Tuesday
Wednesday you get [ __ ] Thursday off
you dick around on Friday is still half
[ __ ] from the [ __ ] barbecue right and
then it's the weekend it's a great
[ __ ] time but when it falls on the
Wednesday those [ __ ] make you come in
Monday Tuesday you take a little bit of
a break then Thursday Friday you know
you're still getting a day off out of it
but you know you know what I mean when
it lands on that Monday or it lands on
that [ __ ] Friday okay my world that's
America if I was president July 4th
would always be on a Monday defin
definitely would be on a Monday every
[ __ ] year and people oh well you know
that actually lands on the 7th and I'd
be like eh who picks up the red phone me
are you all right go [ __ ] yourself there
okay it's on the seventh this year do we
even know that they signed it on the
[ __ ] 4th do we for what's going to
have a new years ago did somebody really
say that do you have any [ __ ] idea oh
by the way I actually saw Abraham
Lincoln vampire hunter this past week
and I got to tell you I got tickets for
free before you think I'm the dumbest
person on the planet but I actually had
faith in that movie because I was like
all right there has to be a reason they
made this because this just seems like
the most ridiculous idea I've ever heard
of my life and I went and I saw it and
there was really no surprise it was
exactly what I thought it was gonna be
it was just a vampire hunter who
happened to be Abraham Lincoln and they
just invented all of this [ __ ] I'm sure
was a good book maybe I don't think it
was it was like some nerd [ __ ] and I
shouldn't have I shouldn't have seen it
that was alright I was drinking when I
saw it I was [ __ ] hammered by the end
of it you know what I mean it's like
when you team goes down 11 runs [ __ ]
two innings in you like [ __ ] it might as
well drink what are the Y's you know is
the worst part was it was in 3d and I
[ __ ] hate 3d movies I really hate
that's just that right there when a
movies in 3d that is a very secretive
little [ __ ] nod and a wink going hey
hey this movie sucks this movie sucks so
bad we had to make [ __ ] float around you
to keep it mildly entertaining
I hate 3d and you know what sucks about
3d now is they [ __ ] it they make it [ __ ]
in 3d that doesn't even need to be in
3d you know back in the day all right
Friday the 13th part three in 3d you
know we shot that [ __ ] arrow when it
comes at yeah all right cool
that was cool but like in nowadays the
guys like Abraham here's your pen I
think I just reads hands upend hey why
is that in 3d am I supposed to do wow it
was almost like he was handing that pen
to me that thing that actually happens
to me in real life that happens to me in
real life
a guy with a hockey mask on shooting an
arrow at me does not [ __ ] happen near
a lake or not near a lake it doesn't
[ __ ] happen make that in 3d don't
just have somebody sitting at a [ __ ]
desk in 3d so I feel like I'm in the
office wow it's so [ __ ] stupid you
know what I mean I know what the [ __ ]
I'm saying anymore you know what how
about how about a little bit of
advertising a little bit advertising
geez I think you putting the [ __ ]
password in this why do I have to have a
password in my computer is if what I'm
doing on this thing is so goddamn
important top secret what is a password
what is the password we can't have the
world have access to your [ __ ] jokes
alright um no I'm in the wrong area here
I'm in the wrong area find it find it
here it is okay quick advertising only
two only two this week all right
amazon.com everybody hey do you go to
amazon.com and you buy yourself some
Freddie Mercury tank tops and dance
around your bathroom you know sweating
it up right well if you'd like to donate
to my podcast and the Wounded Warrior
Project just go to Bill burr com
click on the podcast page take your
pretty little eyes scan over to the
right you're gonna see the amazon banner
you click on that it brings you right to
Amazon and then purchase till your heart
is fulfilled you don't have to buy
anything I'm not saying that there's no
pressure here this is the soft sell I'm
leaning back right now I got my hands up
in the air like hey you know I didn't
touch him I said this out this I'm doing
this whole sales thing okay so don't
feel like I'm pressuring you you can
walk right out of the showroom
I'm alright with it I made myself a
turkey sandwich and an apple I'll take
my lunch it doesn't raise the price or
anything you buy whatever you want on
Amazon
and then they kick a percentage back to
me and I take 10% of that I give it in
and I rounded up to the nearest hundred
I'm gonna actually kick in some even
more I've been been doing alright lately
and it's just a great cause it makes you
feel good
so if you do it god bless you if you
don't I understand
hands are up hey not trying to make you
do anything you don't want sir ma'am
Sonny Boy
all right advertising number two
gamefly.com gamefly.com are you sick of
the real world and want to disappear in
eight thousand video games where you're
a hero instead of the person you truly
are we all do
listen gamefly.com eight thousand videos
that is insane they'll mail them to your
home or their break take them directly
to your PC when you done put playing
them you can mail them back and the
process continues monthly fees are a
fraction of what a new game costs yeah
this is why this totally makes sense
because once you're done with the game
nine times out of ten what do you what
is it what you do is just more clutter
it's just another stack of crap you have
to put in a box when you go to move all
right this is well this is what I would
do if I was a gamer all right if I was a
gamer I would go do gamefly.com I play
all those games I'd send back all the
ones that I'm done with and I don't care
about and then the special ones I just
buy those be perfect then I get to
sample everything you know I mean it's
like finding a wife and you got 8,000
women coming right you get to hook up
with all of them this is like what they
promised the terrorists and you know you
have to blow yourself up this is one of
the greatest things ever the games fit
PlayStation Xbox Wii and even your PC
for Monday morning podcast listeners you
get a free two disc 15 day trial that's
a $23 value that's all it cost
that's almost free but 15 days free
8,000 all the ladies you want that's a
metaphor for games by going to WWF like
ombre or through the banner ad on
billboard comm slash podcast page
alrighty there you go and that's the
advertising for this week wasn't that
pain
by the way by the way I think it's time
I think we're about you know 17 minutes
in I think it's about time I patted
myself on the back how about that
download speed last week huh
how about that I didn't hear any
complaining you know hundreds and
hundreds of people [ __ ] moaning info
right so I finally fixed the goddamn
problem and what do I get I get like
five tweets going eh I really appreciate
it you know what happened to the rest of
you [ __ ] you went on to [ __ ] about
something else you don't like the photo
on my [ __ ] page you know you ever
stop and thinking about you know maybe
finding out what you're really upset
about Jesus Christ could I use that
advice huh um all right let's talk about
something in the news shall we uh hum
actually like I said I didn't even watch
any TV this week this is just a really
weird time of the year for me where the
NHL and the NBA have ended the NFL
hasn't started up yet I'll watch a
little Wimbledon I watched a little bit
of that World Cup soccer I would have a
[ __ ] you call it the European
Championship I wrote for Germany I'm
mostly German you know I root for those
guys who'd they lose through their lust
to Italy and then Spain kick the [ __ ]
out of Italy it's great I can watch any
sport when a championship is on the line
I don't give a [ __ ] what it is cuz you
feel that energy from the [ __ ] crowd
you know what I mean like I would go
like if I was driving by a Little League
field and somebody said that was the
championship game of Little League I
would actually pull over and watch it
from my car like a creepy pedophile no I
would I would I would walk up when I
would sit amongst the parents so they
would they would not feel uncomfortable
but like I don't I don't know I stopped
watching the news years ago it just was
I couldn't watch it anymore the same
reason why I stopped going to church I
was just like this isn't what's going on
what they're telling me isn't is a guess
I just don't buy into it you know other
than that's why I like sports
I like watching ESPN because what they
say is true for the most part the
Phillies did win two to one
there was 30,000 witnesses they saw it
happen but that other [ __ ] when you
start telling me what's going on and
[ __ ] Frankfurt or [ __ ] Vienna or
goddamn [ __ ] Cairo it I don't I don't
know is it is that what happened is that
footage actually from that from that
[ __ ] place did that happen this week
am I still gonna keep asking questions
will this ever end I don't know
I'm sorry you know every once in a while
I get in one of those in my brain it
just I can't I try to get out of it and
I just it's like somebody else takes it
over do you know those kind of people
that do that [ __ ] when they're
explaining something to you and then
they start asking questions for you like
if they were teaching you how to cook
you know so you put the water in the pan
do I bring it to a boil almost do I
throw salt in not necessarily and you're
like dude who the [ __ ] are you talking
to at this point oh here's a nice trick
for you for your pasta that somebody
taught me you pour a little olive oil in
there keeps the pasta from sticking
together you know evidently that's what
the salt is supposed to do I thought it
flavored the water I didn't realize that
was supposed to help not stick together
oh I made a great [ __ ] meal not gonna
lie to you not gonna [ __ ] lie to you
spaghetti and fork and meatballs delish
anyways it's like I said I haven't been
watching a lot of [ __ ] on the news
I just don't watch it you know what I
think they should have to [ __ ] sing
the news the way they do in the Catholic
Church you know there was a guy who got
attacked by two monkeys in South Africa
he decided he was going to go down there
and try to rehabilitate some chimpanzees
that had been abused and they turn
around dragged him for two kilometers
and kicked the [ __ ] out of him what a
dumb [ __ ] why would you fly across the
world to get your [ __ ] ass kicked
do you guys hear about this dude South
Africa Texas student attacked by chimp
in Peru
thank God he improves this poor [ __ ]
bastard he's a ranger right he loves
animals this is the thing about animal
lovers you got to realize that once you
go past a certain level of domestic
animal and you start getting into the
wild no matter how much you love them
they're not gonna love you back
[Music]
wild animals are like that dick you
shouldn't have gone out with you know
that person who cheated on you that
person who just doesn't have you back
wild animals do not have you back your
dog has your back you cat borderline
cats kind of have that creepy vibe that
if [ __ ] went bad they decide what the
the intruder you know what I mean fish
they just don't have any [ __ ] say
they're like a Stepford wife you know
that's why dogs are the best they it's
if they truly [ __ ] love you my dog
[ __ ] loves me
we'll be on a walk and all of a sudden
you just look up me it's almost like
she's smiling
you know how [ __ ] warped a wife sound
she's probably just panting and it looks
like she's smiling it's probably going
like why does he have this [ __ ] rope
around my neck this doesn't make any
sense to me if I really wanted to I
could rip his [ __ ] face off but in my
world I'm so in love with my dog look
she's smiling but that's not bad when
you just have a dog I think people who
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] with animals for a
while wild animals they start thinking
like oh look at the cheetah
oh she's playing and all of a sudden
Groff this [ __ ] launches itself at
you all right I believe that we came
from monkeys I believe that we came from
the apes I believe something else so
there's three in a row and this sounds
smooth but I by no means think that that
those [ __ ] things like us I don't
give a [ __ ] if I teach it sign language
and the chimp sitting there going in
sign language yeah I think you're a cool
guy there freckled-faced [ __ ] you know
there's no [ __ ] way I'm ever going on
the other side of the goddamn cage
this poor bastard was on the other he
was on the other side of the cage he
just got too close that's how [ __ ]
insane a wild animal is chimpanzees they
say have the strength of six six men
this do got attacked by two chimps that
would be like getting attacked by a
flash mob okay like 12 [ __ ] people
they just grabbed this [ __ ] by
his ankles
they reached underneath I mean I don't
kind of [ __ ] cage they had it was
like a compound you know so they put up
that that that cheap wire [ __ ] when you
don't want a rabbit to come in and eat
your lettuce right in your garden like
they put that [ __ ] up so this [ __ ]
guy's sitting there you know is they
gonna doing that [ __ ] and he's like what
are you guys trying to tell me wait
don't tell me all right he's trying to
sign to him you guys want to play
frisbee all right and they're sitting
there talking to each other going just
two more inches two more inches look at
this dumb [ __ ] who wants to play
frisbee right they reach underneath grab
him by his [ __ ] ankles strength of 12
men they [ __ ] pull him right
underneath that goddamn thing like when
you go to Quiznos and they stick your
sub right through that poor excuse for a
[ __ ] brick oven Yankton [ __ ]
right underneath oh my god and then they
dragged him for like another [ __ ] two
kilometers
however [ __ ] far that is I don't know
in my world that's uh what's that about
a mile and a quarter cuz I know like 40
kilometers is like forty miles an hour
who gives a [ __ ] they drag this son of a
[ __ ] basically through the length of
every football stadium in the NFL and I
can guarantee you it wasn't a nice turf
that those guys play on this is the
natural habitat like I can't imagine the
vice grip strength those those [ __ ]
things man they'll rip your foot off the
rip your balls off they'll rip your face
off they'll rip it off like you open a
[ __ ] goddamn thing of yogurt goddamn
ice cream when you just take the lid off
they do that to your face what the [ __ ]
are you doing near these goddamn things
you know jesus [ __ ]
I would have to tranquilizer guns and I
would be wearing one of those [ __ ]
you know the suit you wear when you you
think you're gonna get bitten by a shark
that chain-link [ __ ] there's no [ __ ]
way there's no way [ __ ] catcher's mask
welded to my face I'm not gonna go in
there and not only that these aren't
just regular [ __ ] chimps that have
been swinging around eating bananas
occasionally eating another monkey alive
right this isn't that [ __ ] these are
ones that were abused they were already
[ __ ] with okay and having adopted a
[ __ ] abused dog and the goddamned
schizo [ __ ] that that thing does I can't
[ __ ] imagine a goddamn schizophrenic
[ __ ] eight two of them strength to
twelve goddamn men and you're gonna walk
near the cage trying to sign hey how
about the weather Frank or whatever
[ __ ] human name he gave him
you're right yarder you [ __ ] and god
bless you your hearts in the right place
fortunately this kid doesn't seem like
he had any damage like that but like
this dude was so in shock like they were
finally able to just like stitch him up
and stabilize him and evidently he's not
in critical condition and it doesn't
seem like it seems like he still has his
balls his feet and his face which is
incredible but they say you know he has
bite marks and and fractures plural oh
my god just treating you like a [ __ ]
rag doll that is the most horrifying
[ __ ] in the world to me nature he's the
most horrifying [ __ ] I would rather have
let's see you know what the human
equivalent someone has to come into my
house with a [ __ ] chainsaw I can deal
with the goddamn I could deal with the
machete all right I could deal with that
chainsaw is dead that's hardcore I could
[ __ ] a machete I could deal with I think
I could [ __ ] do the the Sugar Ray
Leonard you know stick my face out and
then pull it back when he took a swing
and then [ __ ] try to take both your
legs
[Laughter]
only hardcore boxing fans got that one
um but I mean if you were in a room with
the chimp and that thing goes [ __ ]
apeshit no pun intended that thing is on
the floor it's up on the ceiling it's
across the room it's like it's like a
comet and you're sitting there dealing
with human speed
dude that's why we got the brains that
we have this white was so much smarter
we have to be because we're so [ __ ]
slow you don't I mean you ever see the
white guy who gets dunked on in those
highlight films you know that [ __ ]
guy that they bring off the bench when
the team's either up by 30 or down by 30
that guy that's what we are in nature
even the [ __ ] athletic humans yet you
know when nowhere near just think like
how fast a [ __ ] snake is a [ __ ]
pit viper viper right it's nothing
[ __ ] you don't eat your bit and that
thing has left left the [ __ ] building
before you even did before that signal
from your [ __ ] leg going hey we just
got bit by a goddamn pit viper even
reaches your brain that snake is already
leaving and then you go and then in the
real is and as the realization that you
got bit hits you you are you're already
collapsing why the [ __ ] would you go out
there you know I don't know we had to be
that [ __ ] smart I can't imagine that
the goddamned fear back in the [ __ ]
day you're walking around with a bunch
of goddamn Neanderthals or whatever
Neanderthals I guess I supposed to say I
said Neanderthal my entire life but it's
Neanderthal I guess and what what else
do was it there was two tribes one of
them died off there was in the antor
tall's and then there was the [ __ ]
crow magnums
and I forget what the [ __ ] we are one of
them one and the other ones the other
one of them was a little bit smarter and
the other ones were a little Dumber and
the Dumber ones died off
alright and some people have a little
bit of that cro-magnon more Neanderthal
in them you know because you know
they're people they [ __ ] right
it's gonna be the dumbest education
little podcast you ever gonna [ __ ]
hear I just totally lost my train of
thought the [ __ ] was I talking about
oh Neanderthals right so I can't imagine
just [ __ ] walkin around did you ever
see that [ __ ] when they did that whole
thing on cro-magnons and Neanderthals
like one of them was like [ __ ] slower
like the [ __ ] white dude in the NBA
and one of them was a little bit quicker
a little bit smarter so they [ __ ] did
this [ __ ] where like when they would
show him like taking down some
prehistoric bison like the [ __ ]
little smarter ones you know they could
[ __ ] you know that that [ __ ] they
could slip a punch they could throw a
goddamn spear they could do they could
do it from a [ __ ] distance like this
[ __ ] jackass he wasn't he was too
close to the goddamn cage the [ __ ]
cro-magnon is one of the Dumber ones
they would like [ __ ] they would just
brute strength they would [ __ ] run
and try to tackle the thing and someone
would you know separate their shoulder a
break and elbow and there's nobody
around to set that [ __ ] every step in
your [ __ ] non-existent shoes and your
big stupid prehistoric foot it's just
having that pain shoot through your body
I just can't imagine I can't imagine
sitting there looking out of a cave and
everything is that much faster than me
and I don't have a [ __ ] door I don't
have a gun you just must be just sitting
here like and he can't really
communicate to the other person because
language hasn't been developed yet so
you just having that what the [ __ ] look
on your face that was probably one of
the first phrases invented like eh you
[ __ ] me or the killer can you
[ __ ] believe us I don't know but God
bless that dude you're an animal lover I
totally know where you're coming from
but for the love of [ __ ] God those
things are not your friends
okay I don't know start p90x in and stay
away from that [ __ ] cage Jesus Christ
can you imagine that I'm getting dragged
away by two [ __ ] abused chimps and
you know goddamn well he saw that
[ __ ] Oh
episode that woman came on with no face
I know he was [ __ ] thinking of that
[ __ ]
I hate those [ __ ]
in orders I like gorillas I hate
chimpanzees and I hate those little
monkeys the little [ __ ] that
throw their [ __ ] at you I can't stand
those [ __ ] and I hate chimpanzees I
always hated those [ __ ] I
didn't know why and now I know why that
was my inner [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
caveman telling me get the [ __ ] out hit
go back to the cave stupid I don't trust
them I don't trust those [ __ ] things
you ever go to the zoo and you just
[ __ ] you just your eyes meet with
like a lion just that [ __ ] look on
their face when they [ __ ] it's I've said
this before it's like what the same look
like when a hooker looks at you like
it's it's the real deal you know this
isn't some [ __ ] [ __ ] flirting
playing hard-to-get get a couple drinks
out of you it's yeah you got 20 bucks I
will suck your dick what you know lions
got that same look on their face like
yeah if you know if you weren't in that
[ __ ] armored vehicle or on the other
side of this yeah if I was hungry I
would eat you and no matter how much you
screamed I wouldn't give a [ __ ] it would
actually excite me more to rip your
[ __ ] head off there's no way there's
no way there's no [ __ ] way
that's why watch all those animal things
man I'm fascinated and I and I and I
appreciate all those people that put
themselves in harm's way because there's
no other way to really gauge how strong
an animal is until you see it slap
around a human being like I can't watch
- [ __ ] grizzly bears wrestle and slap
each other they're in the same weight
class you know I mean if I see him
bitch-slap a human being and watch the
guy's head spin around a couple times
like wow all right I get that
I can now gauge that lit it's like yeah
like like kilometres versus miles all
right I think we killed that subject um
moving along holy [ __ ]
forty minutes in we had a bunch of good
emails this week too so I got to get to
this [ __ ] all right um
by the way if you'd like to email me and
tell me to shut the [ __ ] up or
we question everything the official
podcast email is bill at the mm podcast
calm bill at the capital m capital M
capital P odd cast calm that's it
alright ok here's the first question
alcohol hey [ __ ] what's your
favorite type of beer how often do you
drink hard alcohol
not sure why I want to know so badly but
for some reason I do go [ __ ] a pole you
know people just because I have an
over-the-top podcast doesn't mean that I
don't have feelings too that was a guy
like I've been such a [ __ ] to everybody
who's written into me like he's like
alright I'm gonna be a [ __ ] to you first
so I guess I deserve that
alright what are the questions here
what's your favorite type of beer all
depends it all depends
there's beers that I like because they
take me back to a fun time in my life
Michelob light Budweiser every time if I
haven't had those beers for a while but
globe lights the first beer I got drunk
on and Budweiser was the king of beers
and I can't I was a child into the 80s
where you actually got a tattoo of the
Budweiser label on your arm you know as
opposed to this [ __ ] [ __ ] people do
nowadays with Chinese writing and that's
even old so like whenever I drink that
[ __ ] it just takes me back to like when
I lived in Massachusetts season tickets
to the patch [ __ ] Bruins Boston yeah
you know trying to [ __ ] get laid you
know working in a warehouse no [ __ ]
debt you know all that [ __ ] so I've
tried this Nobby beers you know it's
funny I don't like Belgian beers I don't
mind blue moon but I don't live there
too sweet they got that sweet taste in
him I don't like that I like beer more
with the bite I like German beers yeah
it all depends I had like a [ __ ]
major thing with with Guinness for the
longest [ __ ] time and then I went
over to Ireland and I tried the Guinness
over there and I couldn't tell the
difference I was like I thought it's
supposed to taste better over here and I
drank it all [ __ ] week because I
loved it
and then when I came back to the states
then the [ __ ] that they had in the state
tasted like ass and I've never kind of
been able to go back to it so I don't
know if I answered the question and how
often do I drink hard alcohol not that
much but when I do oh geez I like scotch
I like whiskey I do you know I saw
somebody recently who's been just
drinking non-stop like always embraced
the lifestyle you know cigar smoke and
[ __ ] whiskey drinking hardcore and oh
my god dude you could do that for a
little while but you do that [ __ ] D of
50s man you get like you get that your
bottom lip always looks like you just
put [ __ ] chapstick on it you know and
then you get this big head you look like
this guy he looked like a [ __ ] old
woman I can't even tell he still has
like a great head of hair and he had
like this badass Rockstar haircut that
was a little short but because his head
was so [ __ ] big and his torso was all
[ __ ] you know mantid it out that's
what he looked like
he looked like a Eastern European 60
year old woman you know those women who
look like they could rip a tree out of
the ground I think Bill Maher said that
they asked him why he doesn't drink
anymore he goes yeah you know after a
while you start looking like Ted Kennedy
he's absolutely right
all right beef Curtin advice and for
those of you in the States that's a
slang for the hoo-ha beef curtains
do the math think about it all right you
ready okay here we go here's a situation
I have a wonderful girl in my life
wouldn't when she does not a [ __ ] that's
what I'm guessing I'm guessing this is
where it's going I want to forego my
life great attitude humor big tits nice
ass and a good family Jesus Christ dude
marry this girl sure it seems good for
now but I have one issue she also has
some mean beef curtains any put in
parentheses [ __ ] lips just in case I
didn't know that kind of bugged me
bugged the everliving [ __ ] out of me
whenever we get down to the dirty
business so much so to the point I
looked up some car
medic surgery that basically gives the
beef curtains a trim job and beauty's
the vagina wow dude
Wow all right now before I read the rest
of this if you're gonna [ __ ] ask me
how to have this conversation like
listen love I love you I love you I love
you family I love you your heart
everything but is there any way you
could trim your beef curtains maybe you
can get away with it cuz you got that
cool accent I don't know but she has it
too so she's not gonna give a [ __ ] you
may pull this off with some foreign
chick anyways um so he looks up cosmetic
surgery to try on a beautiful vagina now
I know by now I must sound like a
douchebag focusing on the little things
now because women do that to women focus
on little things like that that's a
serious issue do sex is a big [ __ ]
thing but anyways he says what my
thinking is is I'm truly gonna pull the
trigger he spelt it that way and keep
this woman all to myself for the rest of
my life aren't I entitled to have a
great-looking vag to look at for as long
as our bodies don't wrinkle away Wow I
know there's a lot of women a [ __ ]
annoyed by this one yeah what about you
a [ __ ] dick and your wrinkled balls
once you get a facelift for your sac
there buddy I know they're all saying
that how can I ever bring this option up
to her without I knew he's gonna ask me
without completely destroying her
feelings or making her hate me for being
so [ __ ] conscious
thanks for the read now go [ __ ] yourself
alright this is a simple one dude there
is no way you can bring that up to her
without absolutely completely destroying
her feelings so you either need to
accept this or you have to you have to
let her go that's it that's it I mean I
would think that if you actually truly
cared about this girl
now all the chicks are gonna be like oh
I knew hard underneath all those C words
if you truly care about this girl
I would think that that wouldn't matter
you know and if she looks the way she
she's saying he's saying that she looks
I mean what are we talking here like how
far down are these things hanging is it
like you know it's I mean if she got him
both of them Pierce could you'd like do
like could you like let's bet let's say
could you be like do you like that
Olympic the [ __ ] is that thing you're on
the Rings could you do that and still
swing your feet up and not hit her [ __ ]
are we talking like it's that bad you
know if you did the Iron Cross would
your head be inter [ __ ] like how far
these things hanging down hey now what's
the deal would be Gardens all right dude
there's no way there's there's no
[ __ ] way
and don't don't do that to her cuz she
can't do anything about that if she had
a problem with her [ __ ] vaginal area
you would have known by now because she
would have been self-conscious and she
would have brought it up the way
sometimes girls do about parts of their
bodies and they are super self-conscious
about their bodies because we're so
[ __ ] visual all right I tell you one
time when the first girls I ever hooked
up with when I got her shirt off and her
bra she rolled her eyes and I thought
she was thinking that I was like oh my
god like I'm not doing it for like she's
rolling her eyes like this guy's lame
and I found out later she was
self-conscious about the size of her
breasts so I totally took it the wrong
[ __ ] way I made it all about me
because I'm self-involved so don't do
that to her
all right either you can that that's one
you just suddenly have in your head
either you accept that [ __ ] or you move
on but there's no reason to hurt this
person because you're a shallow [ __ ]
like me all right all right Cheers
sister what is it sister sisters eighth
Christ I can't even [ __ ] read you
know what is I put it into a different
document and it doesn't show it for some
reason capital letters don't show up and
it's this new [ __ ] computer just not
liking it I have to read this because I
think this is a funny title hang on hang
on hang on
[Music]
you know it's funny always hang on hang
on hang on you know what that's from a
long time ago when [ __ ] when Eric
Clapton did unplugged and they played
that stupid would you know like 9
million times that [ __ ] summer and
you want to kill yourself but he's got a
moment of during that that is unplugged
where he starts a song and he [ __ ] up
and he goes uh hang on hang on hang on
hang on some reason that is stuck in a
loop in my head anytime I [ __ ] up I saw
that thing 20 years ago and any time I
[ __ ] up to this day I go hang on hang on
hang on all right sisters a through see
here we go
tired of giving advice to guys with
psycho suicidal girlfriends or people
with STDs well I got something a bit
lighter for you here
kind of like the Coors Light version of
your typical advice thank you and it's
perfect for the middle of summer I
kicked my feet back on this one so I
know this who I've been friends with for
a while now and banged one time she's
the oldest of three sisters so we all
call her sister a about two years ago I
made out with sister be in a club not my
initiative and ended up having sex with
there the same night Jesus Christ dude I
went out with her dude do they have like
that thing on the back of their SUV
where they have the stick figures of the
entire family and you just slowly keep
Xing them out and the family doesn't
understand is somebody trying to kill my
daughters now I'm just trying to [ __ ]
all of them sir well that's a relief
all right um anyways I went out with her
for a while oh this is sister B and it
was surprisingly not awkward when we
were hanging out all together even
though everyone knew the situation Jesus
Christ what southern state are you in
sir
I'll go [ __ ] yourself people down south
that was funny no I'm some months later
sister B left me for one of her one of
my friends and got over it quickly
enough own you got over quickly enough
and nowadays I'm still in contact with
sister a and
since I'm not the kind of guy that holds
a grudge for that kind of stuff well
there you go
it's very mature which means you really
didn't give a [ __ ] about either one of
them so why are you gonna be all upset
you know like you own their [ __ ] once
you [ __ ] it I hate what I hate when guys
do that anyways recently since sister si
started talking to me more frequently
after talking for a bit she said she
could pose for me since I'm a painter
and she's a model and a 10 all the
[ __ ] way I might add oh you [ __ ]
creep you [ __ ] creep you [ __ ]
creep so she was a 10 the whole time so
basically you're in a holding pattern
banging her oldest sister's waiting
until this girl was of age so you could
[ __ ] paint her Jesus Christ I got a
guy you know I might have to stand up
and applaud this one this guy's taking
it to another level
dude this is a [ __ ] epic situation
here so you go see here's my question
does that proposition mean anything
don't you need my advice I need advice
from you how do you [ __ ] every girl in
the same family Jesus Christ this is
like do you know how long this been it's
been since there's been a Triple Crown
winner in horse-racing the last time
someone won the Kentucky Derby the
Preakness and the Breeders Cup is that
what it is or is that a soccer match I
don't [ __ ] know I don't own a [ __ ]
horse since the late 70s I would
guarantee that it's been since the late
70s since somebody has booze bank three
I think a lot can do two in one family
but to get all [ __ ] three dude three
two is respectable three is it no it's
beyond respectable two three okay
everybody knows it's three is in the
sporting we'll do that that's a [ __ ]
dynasty okay you just put yourself in
there with [ __ ] Bill Russell you put
yourself in there with with with the
[ __ ] magic Johnson Lakers you know I
wouldn't say the Kobe Lakers you know
when you go out and you get Phil Jackson
and [ __ ] Shaq then that's that new
[ __ ] that the kids like I don't like
that [ __ ] either way dude you're talking
[ __ ] dynasty oh wait magic never won
three in a row
but he had the Celtics to [ __ ] with name
one three out of four years give me a
[ __ ] break
um so here's my Michael Jordan there we
go so here's my question does that
proposition mean anything is it a trap
should I try to bang her should I try
and bang her too and get a third strike
or keep my dick in my pants and avoid a
potential shitstorm and if yes do you
have any tips special tips on this
special situation all my friends are
telling me to do so but I thought I'd
ask a more refined mine like yourselves
before I did a move dude you're looking
at me like dude you're beyond me right
now okay this is like Bull Durham I'm
[ __ ] Kevin Costner I'm a lifer okay
you're going up to the show
hitting brand new balls every [ __ ]
day I won't you tell me okay I never
banged two girls in one [ __ ] family
you know I was psyched if I was able to
tag a couple of friends and we were all
hanging out at a bar one night and you
get that feeling like I [ __ ] both you
and you both knew it and you both loved
it I hope please please tell me you
liked it did you like it was I okay um
dude I think you got to do it you got to
do it you know you you've been above
board the whole time sister a sister B
they all [ __ ] knew everything right
now I understand this is a little
delicate okay he's trying to snip the
last wire here this is the kid sister
this is it gonna blow up in your [ __ ]
face it's worth it dude it's worth it
it's worth losing a couple of limbs and
your nose on this one you got to do it
the [ __ ] you know dude what the [ __ ] she
says to you yeah you're a painter oh let
me take my clothes off and get paid my
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's not art dude that's
foreplay give me a [ __ ] break
it'd be one thing if you're in a
classroom of people it's just you and
she's standing there naked dude that's
like one of the tips they haven't done
that porn Sinitta that's scenario in a
porno Jesus Christ you might have found
a new angle
dude that's phenomenal that is [ __ ]
phenomenal dude you got to do it
you got a do it did John Elway retire
when he only got one he came back for
another right you got to do it dude dude
what dude that's like when Bush [ __ ]
the first Bush he stopped he didn't get
Saddam you got to go all the way on this
one man
all right you got to be like Marlon
Brando in [ __ ] Apocalypse Now you
just you just you just accept the fact
you left the program all right and I
don't care how mad these girls get dude
you are at the precipice of becoming an
absolute [ __ ] legend legend dude
there are celebrities who've had orgies
they've had five on ones and all that
type of [ __ ] okay but I guarantee you
they never [ __ ] three [ __ ] girls in
the same family when they weren't famous
not famous you're doing this [ __ ] with
the gift of gab whatever the [ __ ] you're
doing dude you do this you got to write
a book you got to write a book that's
foot you know that's you should do
collection of the most amazing [ __ ]
getting stories ever that you can
somehow confirm all right and it has to
be none of that [ __ ] the second you
get famous you get money that doesn't
count
all right that's garbage time okay they
put the [ __ ] second team in there and
you just [ __ ] tit layups that's
[ __ ] I'm talking about just regular
dude you talked yourself into it they
you're a [ __ ] legend you got to do it
all right there's my halftime speech I'm
gonna quote Joe bartnik quoting John
Madden today is gonna be the greatest
day of your life but only if you win all
right you got to do it you got to
[ __ ] do it all right here we go next
one bill fight over a picture with you
darris Billiam my girl and I drove up
from San Francisco to see you in San
Jose you didn't drive up you drove down
if up to you means south I don't know
what the [ __ ] you
and it was awesome thank you we were at
the show where that lunatic in the front
row was giving you a pastry or a pumpkin
after every fourth joke no they won nice
this [ __ ] lady just like lady she
[ __ ] but she made an ac/dc pumpkin
she made a bunch of muffins and she
brought cookies it was like every I
guess I had three jokes about food and
she just sort of brought them up to the
stage she was nice I know what you mean
oh it got a little crazy but it went
when she actually made the ac/dc pumpkin
um anyways I've seen you three or four
times but this is the first time since
I've been listening to the first time
since I've been listening to the podcast
so the show is over and my girl starts
going on and on about how I need to get
a picture with you no offense burr but I
don't want a picture with you or with
anyone
I don't know personally well that's cool
he goes well make it maybe Megan Fox
that totally makes sense
yeah I'm not offended you think I like
[ __ ] standing there at the end of the
show with people with the cell phone
cameras that they hand to somebody else
and they don't know how to work them and
then they [ __ ] you know even when
they hit the right button you got to
stand there for like nine seconds before
it finally clicks it's a nightmare so
I'm glad one less person I had to do
that with so he goes anyways and I just
feel like I was some if I was some
pseudo celebrity I wouldn't want to be
taking pictures with any dudes ooh did
you have to really bring me down to
[ __ ] earth like that you [ __ ] this
guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ] I know what level
I'm at you [ __ ] dick you don't need
to take my knees out anyways what did he
say I don't want to take any pictures
with dudes just chicks yeah that does
make sense is this guy study you like
see how this guy's like like trying to
be my friend while he's subtly giving me
[ __ ] this is I call this the Greg
Fitzsimmons this is what Greg does Greg
complements you and buries the insult in
the middle he's up for all I know
Fitzsimmons is do this Fitzsimmons wrote
this because I think he realizes that I
figured him out so he's like well now
what's another way I can get him I know
I'll send an email and pretend to be
somebody else
sorry that's my conspiracy theory
kicking in anyways that's the whole
point right so I go to the bathroom and
when I get back in the line to get a pic
with you it's about 30 deep my girl at
this point is still nagging after I
already told her I'm not interested in
taking a picture with Bilborough now I
gotta get in now I got to turn into an
[ __ ] because she's still nagging me
about this and I have to certainly say I
don't want to take a picture I'm not
waiting in that line I don't need you
thinking for me let's go well that's
what you should do what you shouldn't do
it with anger so we go outside and she
starts going on and on about me being
homosexual yeah that's her logic I
didn't wait in line to take a picture
with you so that automatically makes me
quit queer he said insert Boston accent
I just kept asking her why was she
trying to start a fight with me we had a
great time and now this I told her my
hero growing up was Chris Cornell and I
wouldn't even want a picture with him or
an autograph I don't understand the
desire to bug complete strangers for a
picture an autograph dude I totally get
this he goes Florentine does it all the
time and brags about it on his podcast
but he thinks black dudes who keep the
tags on their hats or match their shoes
with their hats is gay they're both gay
by the way Oh what getting a picture in
that dude you just took a whole [ __ ]
left turn there he goes my girl isn't a
fan of yours and thinks you're a sexist
pig but you turned her with your
performance in San Jose so what do you
what do you make of this billion yeah
that's weird she didn't like me and then
you go there and then she's demanding
that you get a picture and my queer
because I didn't want to get in line and
wait for you to take a picture for a
half hour with you no you're not you're
a [ __ ] guy who knows what he wants
and he wanted you and you went there you
saw the show you had a good time you
wanted to [ __ ] leave that's what you
should have done and what's with chicks
trying to make you do [ __ ] you don't
want to do I don't know you got to ask
them I have no [ __ ] idea because you
know what it is they feel that they know
what's good for you they honestly feel
that and they'll tell it to you with the
straight face and then all her friends
yeah we do
if you just listen to us ha ha like they
think that they have life figured out
and the reality is is they have a part
of life figured out you know and that's
why you need them you know they have
that [ __ ] let's spruce up the place
let's [ __ ] do some [ __ ] that makes
you feel uncomfortable but secretly you
really want to [ __ ] do you know they
know that so what happens is is I think
that they think that they know that all
the time so that was some [ __ ] we like
dude I don't want to do this and she
thinks that said no you're just being a
guy right now and this is like this is
gonna go into your this is [ __ ] gay
zone so they think you're just being a
[ __ ] macho guy when they don't
realize that sometimes it's like no
seriously I really don't want to do this
I really don't want to go to brunch I
really don't want to go to your
girlfriend's [ __ ] birthday party
where we dress up like it's the 1940s I
really like honestly from the bottom of
my heart I don't want to [ __ ] do this
I don't secretly longed to do this but
I'm worried that my friends are gonna
make fun of me I seriously don't want to
[ __ ] do this okay but the thing is
this guy is you're gonna say it like
that and then they go you know you're
angry why you being mean to me I don't
know that's what chick's trying to make
you do [ __ ] that they don't want you you
don't want to do and also a lot of them
are selfish [ __ ] just like us if they
want to do something they think it's
awesome they can't figure out why you
don't think that it's awesome and he you
know alright I think I explained that 58
[ __ ] times and go [ __ ] yourself with
the pseudo-celebrity that was completely
unnecessary
you know [ __ ] [ __ ] that actually hurt
my feelings even though I know it's true
alright where we go first date and money
I got it I got a step it up here man
what time is it Oh an hour and four I
got to get out of this [ __ ] I got to get
out of here alright first what does
first what's love the podcast but I'm 20
years old still in college and newly
single I decided to try my hand on
dating again I met this girl on Facebook
we message each other for hours before I
decided to ask her out on a date she
accepted Jesus Christ dude she's
probably sitting there like my thumbs
are aching will you [ __ ] ask me out
already she accepted we made plans for
me to pick
this would be the first date I've had in
four months I build replaced with which
was around 20 minutes but from where I
live we went to the mall which is where
everyone basically goes in the weekend
so I thought that I would it would be a
good place to go when we got there we
would decide we were deciding on what to
do that's not a good game plan dude you
should know where you're gonna go and
what you're gonna do just to get it
going so then she do you feel like you
know this guy knows what's what's going
on all of a sudden you're making
decisions and all of a sudden she's
taking her pants off that's how it works
all right you can't go there you can't
treat him like Pierce you got to put
them beneath you you gotta have them
looking at the floor that way they don't
get to say goodnight to nobody
what movie Pope of Greenwich Village I
did a bad version of that um anyways
when we got there we were deciding on
what to do I suggested we watch a movie
but nothing good was playing see you
[ __ ] yourself so instead we decide to
eat dinner Applebee's
we ate at this restaurant in the mall
and talked about getting to know each
other at the end of dinner I paid
because I was told the man pays on a
first date what I wasn't told was
whether or not I should pay for extra
stuff oh my god we started first of all
you already set a precedence that you're
paying the second you pay you're paying
for the whole [ __ ] evening okay and
[ __ ] all the women right now going guys
yeah yes yeah go [ __ ] yourself you
[ __ ] freak [ __ ] we started walking
around and we go into a few stores and
she starts looking at things around the
store saying I wish I had money to do to
buy this I wish I had enough money to
buy that so what I did because I was
trying to be the gentleman and impress
er was offer to pay for those things she
wanted ah dude she you just [ __ ]
yourself she totally doesn't respect you
anymore
you got used I ended up buying her some
sunglasses a shirt a dress and some
shoes and a necklace on a first date
dude
on a first date the first night out with
you just getting to know you you buy her
dinner and all this [ __ ] so you to
realize on the second date if it's gonna
go any further as you know relationship
has to move leg that means you have to
buy her even more [ __ ] all added up to
around 120 bucks not including the
dinner after that I drove her back to
her place and that was it
of course it was
Jesus Christ you bought her a bunch of
[ __ ] like you were already [ __ ] her
that was like her blowing you and then
asking can you take me to a movie yeah
yeah I'll get right on that's not
happening anyways we've gone out four
more times since then of course she is
she's trying to get a whole [ __ ]
wardrobe out of you and the only thing I
got out of this girl was a make-out
session yeah that was a sympathy one to
be honest I wasn't really expecting to
get anything from this girl so why did
you buy her all this [ __ ] dude
you got to work on your self-esteem here
man you setting yourself up to be a SAP
and that's exactly what's happening here
this is all on you and you have the
power to change this [ __ ] all right take
this [ __ ] girl out next time not her
somebody else cuz you've already ruined
it with this one okay find another girl
take her out when you take her out no
where the [ __ ] you gonna go and know
what you're gonna do okay and when she
goes though I wish I had that well hey
you know maybe you ought to work some
overtime this week you know don't say
that but just think that go [ __ ]
yourself and you know and just be silent
when they say that [ __ ] then they'll
realize they overstep some [ __ ] and you
know they probably feel like they got to
make up for it by maybe givin you a
handy um anyway see I'm gonna plow
through this [ __ ] after telling my
friends about the first date whoever all
my friends said what I did was wrong and
I shouldn't have done that all my lady
friends said what I did was sweet and
rare for a guy to do yeah because they
want us to buy him [ __ ] it's got me at
the crossroad of who to listen to more
listen to the guys on your team stop
going on across enemy lines and trying
to figure out what the [ __ ] you're
supposed to do all right [ __ ] all that
the only time you talk to broads is if
you know you're trying it well what
should I get her for her birthday what's
some chick [ __ ] that you guys like
that's what you do okay you don't
[ __ ] ask them you know should I spend
all my money yes wait yeah don't listen
to them listen to your friends to set
you straight dude you dropped 120
[ __ ] bucks and she didn't even get
kissed she got everything she wanted you
didn't get anything yeah [ __ ] all that
dude [ __ ] all that all right
don't ask women advice about [ __ ]
women like that don't okay
immediately you're making it an away
game okay you [ __ ] talk to your guy
friends alright and I'm not talking
about like you know getting Neanderthal
advice because guys will give you stupid
[ __ ] advice to case in point myself
but like when it comes to [ __ ] like that
where you're basically when you feel
like you went too far the women are
always gonna side with going too far in
their direction you know what I mean
that would be like if a girl came up to
a guy and said listen my boyfriend wants
to like you know possibly bring another
girl into the bedroom should I do that I
mean what the [ __ ] are you gonna say and
what are they gonna say you know come on
alright here we go
dilemma Bill imagine you met a girl
she's beautiful
has a great body funny and totally into
you I did she lives with me oh this is a
mixed appoints anyways the night's going
great and you're having a good time
together and she goes home with you so
back at your place you're making out
things are getting pretty hot and heavy
she starts to undress and she has great
tits oh my god then she takes her pants
to reveal she's wearing an adult diaper
if the diaper is unsoiled is it still a
deal-breaker yes it is absolutely 100
[ __ ] percent deal-breaker done over
that's it it's over I'm thinking you
peeing and [ __ ] and my dick has
slumped over and it's like bill do you
enjoy the rest of your evening cuz I'm
calling it a day absolutely a [ __ ]
deal-breaker
abso-fucking-lutely cuz that's gonna
take me but it takes me immediately back
to a horrifying situation that I had I
think I told this story before I'll tell
it really quick cuz I gotta get out of
here hooked up with this girl [ __ ]
hot sexy [ __ ] super tall like model
type chick to the point we would like
doggy style she had to like [ __ ] like
her she was too high
[Laughter]
I'm gonna plow through this because this
is disgusting if you don't like
disgusting stories plow through the next
[ __ ] 30 seconds all right
fast-forward to it all right whatever so
we hooked up and everything we started
in the living room we ended up in the
bedroom okay see you know let's [ __ ]
with this like the trail of clothes the
next morning she's picking up her stuff
I'm trying to help her out I see her
little [ __ ] panties there in the
living room and I went over to him and
there was a oh this freaks me out there
was a [ __ ] I would say at least three
two and a half to three inches [ __ ]
skidmark in her [ __ ] panties I know
disgusting oh yeah so it's a deal
breaker listen to the sound of my voice
when I tell that story it was just it
was [ __ ] horrific alright overrated
underrated underrated moving apartment
okay underrated moving apartment at 6:00
in the morning and drinking J JD at noon
listening to ac/dc on your new balcony
and the Sun while looking at all the
rest of the douchebags unpacking their
truck with [ __ ] they don't need you
moved at 6:00 in the morning and nobody
complain what the [ __ ] do you care right
you're moving out overrated vacuuming
there's no way to do this without
looking at feminity dude that's a
[ __ ] great bit man you could actually
sell it to a comedian you could [ __ ]
kill with that he goes you got a
limp-wristed Lee hold that cord out like
Tinkerbell with a wand
there's just no manly way to vacuum
can't be done it can't that is a woman's
job it's just [ __ ] over there it's
like wearing an apron there's just no
way to do it you the only way to wear an
apron is a guy is it has to be that
solid white one you have to have all the
other white matching [ __ ] like like
you're a [ __ ] gourmet chef and you
have to be a fat gourmet chef other than
that you look like a douche underrating
sweeping good old sweeping with a broom
possibly sawdust from the book
shelf you just built you can get out you
can get your elbows into it no risk
involved yeah but then you get like that
minor lung cuz you kick up all the dust
I'm actually like a neat freak and messy
and I actually enjoy [ __ ] vacuuming
but every once in a while I'll walk by a
mirror and I'll see myself and I will
burst out laughing or I'll immediately
get embarrassed thinking of all my
[ __ ] crazy friends suddenly bursting
and seeing me vacuuming and just
trashing me for unmercifully for like
two hours all right
underrated losing weight once I turned
30 I decided I needed to get back into
shape I was 300 300 pound tub of [ __ ]
and even XXL shirts we're starting to
feel snug at 300 pounds [ __ ] yeah Jesus
Christ I haven't even really put on a
ton of a ton of effort into it yet but
just by lifting weights every other day
riding my bike four or five times a week
and by eating real food I've been losing
about 10 pounds a month for the last
four months good for you dude that's
[ __ ] awesome I love that [ __ ] now the
best part is that for every 10 pounds I
lose the weight of the girls who are
interested goes down by 30 pounds isn't
that sad poor women those dudes don't
have enough people to choose from that's
great dude that's good for you though
and I was thinking being older helps
somehow to maybe it's just knowledge and
confidence but I get hotter chicks now
then I could when I was 21 and in better
shape yeah because you know something
there's also there's there's certain
women out there that they find guys that
a little [ __ ] overweight they find
you less intimidating you know as
opposed to some guy standing there like
a shredded Adonis like believe it or not
they actually get intimidated too you
would think cuz they have the [ __ ]
that they wouldn't but some of them
dopes hour and 60 minutes are running my
Yap look at that I almost brought you
all the way to break time or lunch time
by the time I get this [ __ ] thing up
alright that's the podcast for this week
go [ __ ] yourselves I'll talk to you next
week please keep all the great emails
coming once again the email is bill at
the mmm podcast com
don't take any [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourself
tea next week
you